gabillon l'est demain à 23h45 sur public
sénat
bienvenue dans parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour michael walchhofer et cette
semaine finie les couacs en série sur
les rogues sur la fiscalité l'exécutif
reprend en main la communication du
gouvernement conseil des ministres
enregistré demande d'autorisation avant
de parler l'elysée et matignon recadre
les ministres une semaine marquée aussi
par la polémique sur les rythmes
scolaires séance de questions très
agitée à l'assemblée colère des maires
de droite comme de gauche l'opposition
dénoncent une réforme injuste et mal
financé le ministre vincent peillon est
dans le collimateur et puis le plus de
parlement hebdo notre séquence politique
fiction cette semaine pleins feux sur
les femmes au pouvoir plonger dans
l'univers de borgen la série d'anneaux à
ce qui cartonne et puis la saison 2 des
hommes de l'ombre actuellement en
tournage d'anne frank scénaristes de la
série nous rejoindra à la fin de cette
édition et pour commenter toute cette
actualité fabienne keller bonjour
bonjour sénatrice ump du bas-rhin vice
présidente de la commission des finances
où avait été maire de strasbourg c'était
en 2001 et vous êtes en liste en piste
en tout cas pour cette prochaine
élection municipale de mars prochain
question très simple si jamais
strasbourg retomber dans votre
escarcelle dans l'escarcelle de la
droite est ce que vous diriez que l'ump
aura gagné les élections municipales ma
mon premier objectif c'est de faire
rayonner strasbourg et d'épauler les
habitants alors bien sûr ce serait une
victoire politique
c'est une grande ville c'est une
capitale l'autre capitale la capitale
européenne et puis strasbourg c'est
aussi une mosaïque de quartier avec des
entrepreneurs mais des personnes qui
vivent en difficulté nombreuses aussi
beaucoup de jeunes une ville
universitaire bref c'est une mission
passionnante que de coordonner une
équipe au service des habitants rendez
vous dans six mois en attendant déroule
le fil de la semaine et lundi fabienne
keller on parle du dimanche
qui peu ou pas travailler le dimanche le
sujet ressurgi après les frondes des
enseignes castorama et leroy merlin qui
ont ouverts illégalement le gouvernement
s'empare du dossier pour le confier
finalement à une mission chargée de
réfléchir à un aménagement de la loi
ravi car
ils ont tous répondu à la convocation
les quatre ministres concernés réunis
autour de jean marc ayrault après la
fronde des magasins de bricolage
deux heures de huis clos plus tard le
communiqué de presse de matignon tombe
le premier ministre y rappelle que le
repos dominical est un principe
essentiel à la fois de protection des
salariés de cohésion sociale
cependant le ministre demande des
clarifications et s'en remet à jean paul
bailly pour résoudre ce casse-tête
juridique la réglementation est complexe
et chaque branche a ses spécificités
par exemple les commerces alimentaires
peuvent ouvrir jusqu'à 13 heures les
fleuristes les jardineries les bureaux
de tabac et les magasins d'ameublement
peuvent eux ouvrir toute la journée pour
tous les autres deux clips 2009 la loi
maillé s'applique elle instaure des
zones où l'ouverture des magasins le
dimanche est autorisée ce sont les puces
les périmètres d'usagé de consommation
exceptionnel ce sont des zones de plus
d'un million d'habitants on y compte
aussi les zones touristiques
de plus les mères peuvent accorder des
autorisations exceptionnelles cinq fois
par an les préfets eux peuvent octroyer
des dérogations individuelles pour
raisons économiques
seulement ces dérogations font souvent
l'objet de recours en justice pour
concurrence déloyale des incohérences
que le gouvernement devrait régler sans
heurter les syndicats selon le parti
socialiste
c'est un sujet qui concerne le travail
et sur toutes les questions liées au
travail
la première chose c'est les partenaires
sociaux
ça passe d'abord par la concertation les
magasins qui bravent l'interdiction
d'ouverture risque d'une amende de 120
mille euros par dimanche travaillé en
fabienne keller comment comment ça se
passe chez vous dans le bas-rhin est ce
qu'il ya des dérogations qui peu ou pas
travailler le dimanche et est ce que
surtout c'est aussi la cacophonie alors
effectivement il ya un débat comme
partout en france même si nous avons des
textes de locaux qui complète la
réglementation nationale
je crois qu'il faut être très
pragmatique sur ce sujet on vit aussi le
dimanche donc il ya une attente de
services certains sont d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps autorisé mais le rythme le
rythme de vie partagée est important et
un jour de repos commun basse et des
rencontres familiales des matchs de
sport des enfants qui peuvent être
suivis par les parents on conçoit ça
c'est un débat de société la sondage
ifop 71% des français prêts à travailler
le dimanche 69 pour l'ouverture des
magasins alors qu'il fait et 52 il ya
encore quelques mois on voit que
l'opinion est en train de changer là
aussi oui puis qu'on est tous apprécient
les faits de société c'est à dire à la
fois on est heureux de pouvoir retrouver
nos amis parce qu'ils ont le même jour
de repos que nous et puis c'est bien
confortable de pouvoir faire une course
où donc là toute la question c'est
autoriser le travail le dimanche mais
dans des proportions limitées et pour
des services correspondants un mieux
vivre ensemble qu'est ce que vous
attendez de la mission d'information qui
a été demandé à jean paul bailly par le
gouvernement est ce que vous leur
demandez aux autres de faire un choix
très clair où justement de faire du cas
par cas d'être très pragmatique par
exemple à strasbourg on a une grande
zone touristique c'est difficile le
dimanche d'accepter que trop de
commerces soient fermés il s'agit de
l'est de les accueillir mais par
ailleurs banaliser le dimanche serait
une catastrophe en termes de lien social
est à nouveau de rythme dans la ville il
ne faut pas être trop rigide mais il
faut des rythme partager à cet égard la
comparaison européenne est intéressante
parce que les pays ont adopté différents
dispositifs je crois que c'est en
allemagne qu'il y a dit dimanche qui
peuvent être ouverts en fonction des
situations locales
justement mais en allemagne les
syndicats n'ont n'eussent pas forcément
comme ils le font en france de leurs de
leur pouvoir de blocage de position est
ce qu a votre avis il ne faut pas sur ce
type de sujet des accords de branche
probablement des accords de branche ou
même des accords locaux en fonction des
rythmes de vie locales comme ça à
nouveau il ya chez vous à serait
absolument je pense qu'il faut être très
terrain et reconnaître la dimension
économique du commerce n'est pas
ouvrir pas désorganiser une vie sociale
qui est quand même calé sur un jour de
repos par semaine alors pas si sûr à
notre sujet vous connaissez bien les
centristes fabienne keller a scellé les
gens suivent elles avaient obtenu leurs
journées parlementaires vous savez qu'il
y a en ce moment rapprochement entre
françois bayrou et jean-louis borloo
alors pour l'instant la noce se passe
pas trop mal en tout cas les termes du
contrat eux sont plus difficiles à
mettre en place des explications de
françois goulet
voilà une petite année que lui dei a vu
le jour alors cette journée
parlementaire c'est l'occasion de faire
le bilan mais c'est surtout l'union avec
le modem qui occupe tous les esprits
si les deux baies bayrou et borloo ont
multiplié les préparatifs de fiançailles
ces dernières semaines
le mariage n'est pas encore consommée
d'ailleurs presque aucun parlementaire
moderne les venues aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'alliance est engagée elle
n'est pas encore scellé il reste à
l'inscrire dans le marbre à rédiger un
papier très clair sur nos engagements et
notre positionnement donc aujourd'hui il
est logique que l'on soit dans un
rassemblement des parlementaires de
l'udps et mais sur le fond tout le monde
est d'accord le centre doit s'unir face
au gouvernement quitte à en oublier les
années de querelles passées le modem qui
avait soutenu françois hollande
considère que c'est pas possible que que
ce que
ils sont pas au rendez vous des réformes
et qui sont maintenant dans l'opposition
si c'est dans l'opposition c'est pour
construire un projet juste pour
critiquer j'imagine bon et donc si c'est
le cas le différend que nous avions ou
la différence que nous avions elle
s'estompe même son de cloche du côté du
modem si les deux courts on s'associe
personne n'a de visée hégémonique
il ya une volonté de travailler ensemble
alors quand on a une volonté de
travailler ensemble on cherche pas comme
ça à prendre le dessus on sait
simplement qu'il faut se respecter les
uns les autres faut respecter les
identités des uns et des autres on a des
histoires séparées on a oui les nuances
et on a envie de surmonter cela et de
faire en sorte que et bien cette
addition de différence face une force
nouvelle le rapport de force a bien
changé en moins d'un an lui d y marquent
le tempo désormais au centre quand le
modem compte une vingtaine de
parlementaires lui d y en a trois fois
plus
alors j'imagine que le sort des
centristes vous intéresse donc est ce
que votre avis ce mariage va fonctionner
écoutez voilà des personnes qui
partagent des convictions communes que
je partage très largement également il à
l'ump on voit là il y à des centristes
nombreux à l'ump conduits par des
personnalités comme jean pierre raffarin
ou monsieur leonetti il y a même s'il
est radical il y à une sorte le commun
et ce socle c'est l'humanisme c'est
l'europe qui va être un sujet
d'actualité du fait des élections c'est
aussi l'élection
alors disons que les élections mettent
en lumière le besoin d'un projet
européen et puis c'est aussi une vision
de la société moi j'ai en charge à
strasbourg j'ai très bien travaillé avec
jean louis borloo sur la rénovation
urbaine la dignité retrouvée pour les
habitants du quartier complètement est
ce que vous voyez françois bayrou faire
une opa sur les i je crois qu'il se
retrouve jean louis borloo et françois
bayrou ils se connaissent et son nom de
bois fabienne keller jeu je crois que
françois bayrou est revenu à un certain
réalisme et il voit bien que le
gouvernement qui l'a dont il a soutenu
l'élection il a soutenu françois
hollande est très désespérant pour la
france et pour les français ce que vous
croyez vraiment à une recomposition du
ce ce qu'il ya vraiment une place pour
le centre quand on voit un front
national aussi fort en tout cas comme le
prédisent les sondages qui a vraiment
cette place alors pour ma part je suis
centriste au sein de l'ump et j'ai fait
le choix de faire vivre cette
sensibilité au sein d'un mouvement
fédérateur qui rassemble des personnes
qui ont des sensibilités qui peuvent
être un peu différente il y a une force
centriste qui est en train de
s'organiser et là elle a sa place mais
je me sens évidemment très proches alors
fabienne keller mardi c'est une question
de rythme à l'assemblée
l'ump en a fait son angle d'attaqué
avant les municipales le parti a diffusé
un tract à un million d'exemplaires pour
demander leur le report de la réforme
peillon sur les rythmes scolaires jugé
injuste mal préparée et mal financée à
l'assemblée jean françois copé a
interpellé le ministre écoute et vous
avez décidé cette réforme des rythmes
scolaires en catimini par décret des
enfants monsieur le ministre nous en
avons tous les témoignages les enfants
sont épuisés par l'augmentation du temps
scolaire
ça ne peut pas être en augmentant les
impôts locaux alors que vous avez
matraquer les français comme vous l'avez
fait part des impôts d'état que vous
trouverez la solution je vous demande
donc de reporter cette réforme avant que
la colère du peuple de france ne vous
oblige à des missions à réformes que
nous menons y compris avec des élus de
votre bord politique
elle est une grande elle vous plait côté
permettre à chacun de se dépasser car
nous savons en effet que lorsque l'école
de la france marchera mieux alors si
l'ensemble du pays qui marchera mieux
nous vous attendons à ce rendez vous on
a compris que vous aviez un rendez vous
politique avec les municipales faites
attention ne pas enfourcher ce cheval
vous risquez de tomber et la chute sera
lourd
alors hier tout le monde semblait plutôt
assez d'accord notamment à l'ump avec
cette réforme n'est aujourd'hui tout le
monde est contre pourquoi ce brusque
changement de position a plutôt d'accord
ce n'est pas exact si 2010 en
augmentation
attendez michèle tabarot ump qui dit oui
il faut changer quatre jours quatre
jours et demi la question du rythme de
vie des enfants du fait qu'ils ont peu
de jours de classe par rapport aux 365
jours de l'année est posée et un débat a
été très largement ouvert par luc chatel
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est la solution
qui a été imposé par vincent peillon et
quatre jours et demi les quatre jours et
demi une réforme venu d'en présenter
assez tardivement et sans consulter les
centaines de milliers de personnes dont
il s'agit et qu'il faut accompagner je
ne parle pas des enfants là je suis sur
les professionnels les enseignants et
l'ensemble des
acteurs du monde associatif qui doivent
animer les séquences qui sont prévus
pour l'ouverture pour ce temps
périscolaire et puis les mairies qui
sont priés de tout organiser tout ça a
été fait dans la précipitation sans
aucune prise en compte de l'enfant au
fond le seul sujet ici ça devrait être
l'enfant son rythme est ce qu'on lui
propose en terminant même les
chronobiologistes les professeurs tout
le monde avait l'air de dire oui il faut
appliquer les quatre jours et demi donc
pourquoi aujourd'hui l'ump est vent
debout sur cette position alors que vous
l'aviez en 2010 tout le monde était
d'accord sur le fait que les enfants
n'avait pas un bon rythme donc il
fallait changer le rythme mais pas
n'importe comment mais comment alors
justement quel que soit le bon rythme
pour c'est très fort je ne veux pas
prétendre être meilleur que les grands
spécialistes les chercheurs et les
enseignants et les parents d'élèves
impliqué c'est toutes ces personnes
chaque fois autour de chaque école qu'il
s'agit de mobiliser pour réfléchir
ensemble au bon rythme et aux bonnes
activités et ça se décrète pas et puis
là des problèmes d'argent c'est un
simple d'organisation ou de financement
avant tout servir de réalité terrain et
de vécu c'est un problème très humain
est ce qu'on propose aux enfants plutôt
des activités culturelles des activités
autour de l'environnement du sport ou
juste de la garderie ce qui semble être
le cas dans certains endroits recréant
une inégalité que l'école républicaine a
permis de préserver alors moi je suis à
titre personnel un produit de l'école
républicaine donc donner à chacun à
chaque enfant les mêmes
c'est pour moi non négociable et cette
réforme mal portait mal engagé qui n'a
pas pris le temps de sa mise en oeuvre
eh bien c'est ce de se prendre le risque
de casser ce pactole bill keller reste
que c'est un thème très porteur pour
l'ump parce que là on parle de la
famille des enfants ça vous rappelle pas
un peu le débat sur le mariage pourtant
vous êtes en tactique et j'essaye de
vous répondre autour de la question de
langue politicienne aussi donc je vous
réponds je vous pose la question autour
d'eux en tant que politicienne dont on
voit bien que la forcément il y un
rapport avec les élections municipales
vous pouvez pas le cacher bien sûr nous
sommes dans le débat politique et le
débat politique il peut être fructueux
nous avons six mois de débats à
l'occasion des municipales
c'est le mans n'ont d'évoquer la prise
en compte de l'enfant puisque la prise
en charge des écoles c'est une très
belle mission des mairies et que les
maires les 36000 maires de france s'y
attelle avec beaucoup d'engagement et
notamment dans les petites communes
tiennent beaucoup à leur école donc ré
ouvrir un débat sur la famille oui il
est apparu au moment du débat mariage
pour tous mais il n'a pas été poursuivi
la famille socle de la société mais
aussi remise en cause quand la moitié
des enfants naissent en dehors du
mariage donc quelles nouvelles formes
des familles qu'elles accompagnent ce
n'est pas le cas on va avancer un petit
peu mois passés au mercredi au jour du
conseil des ministres et françois
hollande qui recadre ses ministres
alors après les polémiques en série
visiblement le président de la
république a voulu taper du poing sur la
table et faire preuve de fermeté
l'exécutif a même donné des consignes
très claires pour contrôler la
communication démoniste il faudra passer
par matignon les explications johan raud
là le ton semble bel et bien s'être
durci au dernier conseil des ministres
après la polémique valls duflot de la
semaine dernière aucun commentaire des
deux intéressés un recadrage ce matin
c'est bien la porte parole du
gouvernement confirme pour sa part qu'il
ya bel et bien été question de recadrage
présent la république a rappelé aux
ministres les règles qu'ils doivent
respecter collégialité solidarité et que
s'il subsiste une dissension entre
ministres et bien doit être arbitrée en
interne par le président lui-même au
prochain quoique aurait averti le chef
de l'état ce sera la porte le message
audio aurait même été enregistré lors du
conseil des ministres histoire de
redresser la barre après une semaine
marquée par des critiques sur le manque
d'autorité de françois hollande confirmé
dans son rôle de grand coordinateur de
la parole gouvernementale jean marc
ayrault enfonce le clou tant mieux
qu'ils aient des personnalités dans un
gouvernement et qu'elles soient diverses
mais un gouvernement ce n'est pas une
addition
d'individualités après avoir à deux
reprises volé la vedette à manuel valls
lors des questions au gouvernement
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur si le premier
ministre veut bien aujourd'hui vous
laisser répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
mais cette marque de fermeté est aussi
un risque d'implosion alors que le
premier ministre laissait entendre que
manuel valls regretter ses propos sur
les roms l'entourage du ministre de
l'intérieur dément telle information
hier soir la nouvelle ligne
gouvernementale s'appliquera-t-elle
aussi aux proches des ministres une
autre polémique agite déjà la toile un
tweet de xavier cantat compagnon de
cécile duflot justement consacré à cette
question du recadrage fabienne keller
qui recadrait dans cette histoire le
premier ministre chargé de tenir ses
troupes pour les ministres c'est l'image
catastrophique d'un gouvernement qui
gère des égouts et pas de projet pas de
volonté de travailler en équipe quand je
vois christiane taubira et manuel valls
développer une polémique par médias
interposés sur le sujet tellement
essentiel pour nos concitoyens qu'est la
sécurité moi je dis c'est
ben là ils ont chacun un domaine en
charge mais ils ont tout autant la
responsabilité de travailler ensemble
pour se coordonner les policiers et les
acteurs du monde de la justice ces deux
piliers de la sécurité de la l'assurance
de l'application des lois pour tous les
français ils doivent se mettre d'accord
et si long des débats ils doivent être
entre eux et en amont il passe devant
les français alors sur la sur la méthode
employée de la méthode de recadrage est
ce que cette ligne de code et et nabeul
et ce qu'il faudrait pas aussi cornaquer
contrôler les conjoints qui envoient des
tweets
arrêté sur le sujet nicolas beaumont et
voilà maître d'école c'est grave qu'ils
doivent en arriver là a tapé avec une
règle sur le bout des doigts de chacun
c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut construire
un projet pour la france il faut une
vision partagée et que chacun déploie
toute son énergie et toute sa compétence
il ya la jurisprudence delphine batho
ils sont tous paralysés dans leurs
actions
là où l'état de la france au contraire
imposerait d'avoir des personnalités
fortes volontaire et portant un but d'un
projet à part celle de salles pour la
société qui a peut-être trop de
personnalités fortes dans ce
gouvernement il faut des personnalités
fortes pour redresser la france mais des
personnalités fortes qui travaillent
ensemble aujourd'hui où rien ne peut
s'organiser sans que plusieurs
ministères travaillent ensemble
aujourd'hui ils sont incapables de le
faire c'est absolument dramatique et au
passage par différence on voit que
françois fillon a fait un formidable
travail de coordination du gouvernement
des couacs au sol et je dois dire qu'au
niveau local c'est la même réalité dans
ma ville comme strasbourg aujourd'hui
monsieur rice a beaucoup de mal avec ses
adjoints eh bien ça fait que la ville
est moins puissante et arrive mans à
agir concrètement au service des
habitants et quelque part les élus
perdent un peu l'objectif de leur
mission qui est de servir qui est de
s'occuper des gens des élus qui agissent
avec plus de transparence en tout cas
c'est le mot d'ordre à l'assemblée au
palais bourbon le voleur de claude
bartolone le président de l'assemblée a
présenté le bilan d'un an de législature
des lobbys mieux encadrer plus de
contrôle sur l'utilisation de la fameuse
réserve parlementaire écouter président
soleil
il y un an je m'engageais à ce que le
voile soit levé et l'arbitraire rompu en
ce qui concerne la réserve parlementaire
parole tenue nous avons changé la règle
du jeu en faveur de plus d'équité
dorénavant un député de l'opposition
dispose d'autant de crédit qu un député
de la majorité
de plus de transparence
l'assemblée nationale publiera en fin
d'année l'utilisation qui en a été fait
par chaque député il y un an je
m'engageais à réglementer l'activité des
représentants d'intérêts à l'assemblée
nationale parole tenue le 27 février
2013 monsieur christophe sirugue vice
président de l'assemblée nationale a
remis un rapport sur le lobbying à
l'assemblée plusieurs des
recommandations de ce rapport sont
entrées en application hier
est-ce que sur ces questions fabienne
keller les lobbys la réserve
parlementaire donc le contrôle
finalement de l'exécutif l'assemblée
aujourd'hui à un temps d'avancé sur le
sénat le sénat est assez performant
rossi
et des exemples peut-être sur le fond
moi je crois que vraiment les temps ont
changé l'exigence de nos concitoyens est
forte et donc moi je suis favorable à la
transparence donc le sénat joue le jeu
de la transparence lui aussi et goûtez
moi je peux vous dire qu'à titre
personnel j'ai publié l'ensemble des
éléments de ma rémunération mon
patrimoine
l'utilisation de la réserve
parlementaire et l'utilisation des frais
de parlementaires sur mon site internet
ça me semble comment dire une
orientation peut-être que nous inspirent
les nordiques les suédois les danois et
qui va dans le sens d'une confiance
qu'il nous faut reconstruire avec nos
concitoyens il se méfie de tout ce qui
est caché donc au delà des contrôles
évoquée par le président de l'assemblée
nationale
à l'instant je pense que c'est la
transparence dire les choses dire ce
qu'on fait il a dit aussi a beaucoup
parlé des contrôles de la loi il va
lancer plusieurs missions d'information
notamment pour voir où en est la loi
aujourd'hui ça s'applique c'est bien ce
qu'il fait c'est c'est plutôt juste pour
le rôle des parlementaires je serai
bientôt évidemment on recensait le sénat
le fait depuis très longtemps et à titre
personnel j'ai fait beaucoup de
contrôles d'application de la loi j'ai
longtemps eu en charge le budget de
l'environnement j'ai fait des contrôles
sur l'application des directives
européennes et c'est passionnant et cela
permet de relier leurs livres c'est quoi
l'idée c'est qu'on applique vraiment les
rois et bien qu'on ne met pas toujours
les moyens budgétaires nécessaires à
différents niveaux qui dit aussi des
responsabilités partagées exemple sur la
qualité de l'eau il faut travailler avec
les syndicats locaux intercommunaux qui
gère l'eau comme avec les préfectures
avec le niveau national et appliquer les
directives européennes donc il faut pas
être dans le rejet de responsabilité il
faut être dans le travail ensemble est
ce que vous direz que les lobbys
aujourd'hui sont mieux encadrer ces
mêmes lobby qui ont une influence forte
sur la rédaction de certains articles
sur l' élection certaine que j'ai envie
de vous dire qu'on n'est pas du tout
dans un système à l'américaine
aujourd'hui en france donc les lobbys ne
nous faisons pas trop peur le morceau
voilà moins loin que parlement européen
tout à fait globalement que le monde
anglo saxon mais néanmoins mêmes règles
la transparence dire les choses si des
personnes qui représentent un lobby
pénètre dans nos commissions dans nos
murs
faisons le savoir pour que tout le monde
en soit conscient
jeudi fabienne keller la constitution
française fête ses 55 ans
de nombreux ministres et ex ministre de
la vème république étaient présents pour
célébrer l'événement françois hollande a
aussi saisi l'occasion de cet
anniversaire pour faire une annonce pas
de révision constitutionnelle ni de 6ème
république mais un appel à l'arbitrage
du peuple
la révision constitutionnelle de 2008
avait prévu le référendum d'initiative
populaire
la loi organique permettant
l'application de cette mesure n'a
toujours pas été adopté j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de soumettre un projet au
parlement avant la fin de l'année alors
ce référendum d'initiative populaire
c'était donc une grande promesse de
nicolas sarkozy finalement c'est
françois hollande qui qui annonce qui va
la mettre en oeuvre et ce qu'il n'a pas
fait marche arrière par peur de voir
instaurer la un contre-pouvoir vous tend
les de sarkozy je parle de nicolas
sarkozy moi je j'ai envie de faire la
lecture à peu près un vrai ça c'est
françois hollande qui ce qui chaussent
les pantoufles de nicolas sarkozy pour
enfin prendre une mesure forte et
symbolique il a tant de mal à en
construire lui-même sur l'emploi sur des
sujets de société pour une fois une
proposition de loi qui fait consensus et
oui bah oui mais c'est celle de sarko
c'est comme ça c'est celle du précédent
gouvernement ils apprécient notre
majorité ce qui n'est toujours pas en
vigueur qu est-ce qui s qui s'est fait
sèchement techniquement je n'ai pas la
réponse et c'est une bonne chose c'était
une conviction forte du précédent
président il souhaitait pouvoir donner
la parole au peuple alors il faut il
faut s'assurer que voilà mais les autres
le parlement ne sont pas des saisies de
leurs responsables et reste précise
quand même la mise en vente bon
équilibre à l'image de ce qui existe au
niveau européen aussi où le parlement
peut être interpellé 6 1 millions au
moins de citoyens européens l'exigent si
jamais aujourd'hui il y avait un
référendum quel serait pour vous en tout
cas la question qu'il faudrait poser en
priorité aux français
alors oui question piège il faut faire
bon usage du référendum
puisque les français ne répondent pas
toujours à la question posée comme on
l'a vu sur le référendum européen cela
constitue son temps à parler tout à
l'heure la régie moi je ne suis pas sûr
vous voyez vie
priorité soit de cliver c'est-à-dire de
séparer entre les français qui dirait
oui et qui dirait non à une question
trop cinq ans et a dû retrouver c'est le
but oui mais moi qui vais beaucoup à la
rencontre des strasbourgeois en
l'occurrence depuis de nombreux mois
j'ai plutôt envie de dire que les
français ont envie de dialogue de débat
sur les questions évoquées tout à
l'heure comme la famille sur comment on
pourrait redémarrer la france on
al'exemple strasbourg si vous deviez
faire un référendum de basse après sur
quoi écouter sur quelque chose peut-être
sur l'enfant sur sur le vivre ensemble
sur l'éducation sur sur ce que ce qui
fait ciment mais à nouveau plus qu'un
référendum avec une question simple
hyper simplifiée plutôt un vaste débat
qui permet de d'exprimer la richesse
l'un d'eux ce que sont les engagements
des français et leur conviction de
démocratie participative plus de
dialogue avec le terrain oui et on de la
démocratie et du dialogue de l'action
moi je ressens que si la france comme ma
ville s'en sortiront c'est grâce à des
entrepreneurs qui agiront des personnes
qui s'engageront dans leur assaut ce
dans leur école dans leur sera je vais
l'être mots de votre votre campagne
c'est ce que vous essayez de mettre en
oeuvre pour votre camp je pense que
c'est c'est comme cela aussi que nous
pourrons réconcilier la politique et des
citoyens en construisant des projets
avec e.on laissant à chacun sa liberté
mais en les épaulant c'est ça le
l'action publique fabienne keller vous
êtes vice présidente de la commission
des finances vous avez vu est
certainement passer le nombre évidemment
très important de projets de loi sur sur
la finance qui aura bientôt ce projet
qui arrive en commission en tout cas la
semaine prochaine à l'assemblée des élus
ump ont mené cette semaine une offensive
ils ont présenté ce qu'on va appeler un
contre budget aurait buffard charleville
à 9
baisser les dépenses plutôt qu'augmenter
les impôts c'est le principe sur lequel
l'ump dit s'appuyer pour bâtir son
budget les députés de l'opposition
voudraient annuler certaines hausse
estimée à près de 5 milliards d'euros il
ya celles qui massacrent un peu le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages donc je
pense par exemple au quotient familial
qui est raboté d'année en année par le
gouvernement et puis sur les entreprises
il ya des parades aux complet il ya une
contradiction totale d'un côté on dit
qu'il faut la compétitivité et de
l'autre on va augmenter les impôts des
entreprises dans le viseur de
l'opposition notamment la création de la
taxe sur l'excédent brut d'exploitation
des entreprises pour financer ces
baisses d'impôts l'opposition veut
réduire les dépenses elle propose de
rétablir certaines réformes mises en
place par le gouvernement de françois
fillon comme la révision générale des
politiques publiques ou le jour de
carence dans la fonction publique autre
priorité pour l'ump réduire le nombre de
fonctionnaires dans l'immédiat
les économies les plus importantes sont
à attendre de la masse salariale des
fonctions publiques en incluant dans
cette masse salariale également les
retraites là c'est un enjeu de plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'aud l'ump
propose aussi de tailler dans les
dépenses sociales avec notamment
l'attribution des aides au logement
selon des critères sociaux pour les
étudiants ou la restriction du nombre de
bénéficiaires de la prime pour l'emploi
ces questions sociales que j'ai envie de
vous poser la première question parmi
les pistes avancées par l'ump la prime
pour l'emploi uniquement pour les plus
modestes c'est juste alors les
dispositifs de compensation au chômage
ou d'accompagnement du retour à l'emploi
sont devenues très compliquées
et l'idée de les regrouper pour les
clarifier et pour clairement avoir un
objectif simple qui est de permettre une
meilleure rémunération pour ceux qui
travaillent même si c'est à temps
partiel même si c'est un cdd vont dans
le bon sens c'est juste
là le l'important est dans le détail
l'idée c'est de regrouper ces aides pour
qu'ils aillent dans le sens de la prime
à celui qui bosse c'est un sujet
absolument stratégique et il faut le
savoir qui le différencie qui nous
différencie fortement de l'allemagne
c'est papa d'asti stade assez c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est que aujourd'hui
une personne qui est aux minima sociaux
et qui travaille peut se trouver quand
elle est à nouveau en difficulté en
situation de baisse de revenus de baisse
de couverture notamment la cmu la
couverture santé et ça c'est
inadmissible
il faut avoir une prime pour l'emploi
qui est vraiment ce qu'ils prennent des
mesures sociales exemple encore des
propositions ump des critères nationaux
pour les prestations handicap uniquement
des critères nationaux peuvent alors le
handicap est un sujet très humain là
aussi aux mains des départements il faut
sûrement évaluer ce qui se passe dans
les départements pour qu'il y ait une
équité dans semble assurée sur le
territoire national mais je crois pas
que ce soit des critères qui permettent
donc en désaccord avec une partie des
propositions faites je vais en parler le
garage proposer le jeu propose d'avoir
une appréciation plus locale parce que
les aides aux handicapés alors la
personne handicapée c'est quelque chose
qui évolue dans le temps qui prend en
compte l'état de la personne c'est pas
quelque chose qui se prête aux critères
même s'ils sont nombreux sur la
philosophie générale de ce contre budget
est ce qu'un projet de loi de finances
comme ça sans hausse d'impôts c'est
réaliste alors que est ce que la france
peut vraiment se le permettre alors que
dans tous les pays d'europe on est
obligé quand même d'augmenter les impôts
alors hein je trouve très courageux de
la part de gilles carez de faire ces
propositions sont pas évident de faire
des propositions d'économies je
reconnais bien là son sens de la
responsabilité et puis sa forte
connaissance indue du budget de l'état
par ailleurs les impôts augmentent très
très fortement un seul chiffre plus 12
milliards d'euros sur l'impôt sur le
revenu de 59 72 milliards entre 2012 et
2013 et d'ailleurs tous les français
s'en rendent compte nous recevrons tous
en ce moment nos impôts à payer quel est
le juste niveau puisqu'il faut bien en
même temps régler le problème de la
dette astronomique française qui la
dette astronomique y progrès elle
continue à progresser elles représentent
aujourd'hui
97% du pib de la france donc les mesures
que propose le gouvernement un
pénalisent les français puisque la
fiscalité va encore augmenter l'année
prochaine sur l'impôt sur le revenu que
je citais ont fait 5 milliards de plus
donc ça va continuer à augmenter les
impôts locaux augmentent dans de
nombreuses villes souvent socialiste
donc je disais le déficit ne se ne
recule pas donc toute la question c'est
de faire redémarrer la machine
économique parce que c'est celle qui
produit des cotisations sociales de
l'impôt sur les sociétés de l'emploi et
du revenu pour des millions de français
alors fabienne keller ya comme des
sujets qui font qu'il faut consensus
puisque la majorité a apporté cette
semaine ses voix à l'opposition c'est un
fait rare ça se passait à l'assemblée la
gauche a voté pour la proposition de loi
ump qui vise à soutenir les petites
librairies indépendantes le prix d'un
livre acheté en ligne ne pourra plus
être inférieur de 5% toute réduction
confondues message à destination du
géant amazon est ce que pour vous cette
proposition de loi va vraiment dissuader
des géants du livre comme du livre en
ligne comme amazon de pratiquer
c'est cette concurrence je veux vous
dire je veux témoigner que des petites
librairies dont les quartiers de
strasbourg apporte un plus en proximité
pour les enfants les jeunes du quartier
pour qu'ils puissent voilà choisir
facilement un ouvrage en terme
d'animation parce qu'ils font venir
quelqu'un qui dédicace à un ouvrage donc
tout tout geste qui permet de tenter de
préserver cette vision très très
européenne un très française du commerce
de proximité de du de la vie un pardon
intellectuelle de l'animation à travers
une activité économique qui est le
commerce du libraire va dans le bon sens
est-ce que ça va empêcher le géant
d'internet et
c'est pas sûr mais j'observe
qu'aujourd'hui nos concitoyens cherche
aussi le contact nous en avons tous les
mares de tapoter sur des machines pour
chercher un ticket de transport pour
commander un billet de train pour faire
tous les actes de la vie et qu'on
recherche cette qualité de relation il
faut bien pouvoir pour préserver ce
modèle économique c'est vrai m'ayant
tabilité aussi de cm2 de prix ou ce
moment donné parce que amazon a répondu
en disant que finalement c'est le
consommateur qui va au final être
pénalisés parce qu'ils devraient payer
plus cher alors le consommateur peut
faire son choix d'abord et puis il faut
je crois que sur les sujets culturels et
intellectuels il faut veiller à
préserver notre patrimoine
nos traditions ce qui fait la richesse
aussi peut-être de la france ce qui fait
que les touristes viennent nombreux par
rapport à d'autres pays cet art de vivre
cette capacité à débattre réfléchir bas
c'est aussi grâce à la diffusion du
livre mais aussi des vidéos mais aussi
des
référés télé je fais la liaison vous
avez peut-être vu en tout cas les deux
séries un peu à ses phares en ce moment
sur nos télés et sur nos ordinateurs
fabienne keller c'est notre plus de
l'hebdo
alors quel est le rapport entre la série
danoise borgen dont arte diffuse la
troisième saison de la série française
les hommes de l'ombre bah tout
simplement les femmes en politique ccimo
barbarie qui nous explique tout ça
quand les séries s'emparent du pouvoir
c'est sous les traits d'une femme qu'il
s'incarne à l'image de borgen le
désormais incontournable feuilleton
danois la troisième et ultime saison de
cette fiction politique est actuellement
sur nos écrans l'héroïne birgit nous
borg ancienne première ministre du
danemark prépare dans ce dernier volet
son come back en politique le personnage
est une combattante avec des convictions
des vraies mais n'est pas prête à tout
pour les faire triompher en tout cas je
ne foulerait pas au pied des principes
fondamentaux simplement pour laisser mon
empreinte sur un accord économique tout
à fait insignifiant en méprisant les
droits de l'homme qui sont pour le parti
centriste l'axé principal de sa
politique est une de ses priorités pas
de cynisme mais pas d'angélisme non plus
dans cette description au cordeau de la
démocratie moderne l'action est ici
réduite à son minimum et se concentrent
dans l'alternance des scènes intimes et
public bergui tu tu n'étais jamais là tu
bossais 24 heures sur 24 ça ne collait
fremm ça ne pouvait évidemment pas
recoller félipe on venait de me nommer
premier ministre
changement de décor et de styles avec la
série française les hommes de l'ombre
sorti en début d'année cette fois ci
aussi les femmes sont au coeur du
pouvoir le personnage de nathalie baye
sera même dans la course à l'élection
présidentielle la différence de morgen
l'intriguent privilégie le terrain de la
communication et a tendance à délaisser
celui des idées l'accent est mis sur ces
hommes de l'ombre ces conseillers qui
entoure les dirigeants je représente
l'aide avec damon
et organisera et la communication de la
campagne avec toi c'est officiel vous
vous présenter
alors qu'en france moins de 30% de
femmes sont représentées au parlement
c'est à se demander si la fiction n'a
pas une fois encore un temps d'avancé
sur la réalité
et nous accueillons dans parlement hebdo
d'anne frank bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous avez beaucoup
écrit oeuvre littéraire écrit pour le
cinéma pour la télévision
actuellement à les hommes de l'ombre la
saison 2 est en tournage ait eu un gros
succès pour la saison 1 une question
simple pourquoi
ce choix de des femmes dans votre
feuilleton pourquoi pourquoi avoir
choisi un objectif et une petite chose
je suis un des créateurs de la série et
créateur des personnages mais je n'ai
pas travaillé sur la deuxième saison
voilà donc s'expliquer la première
montre donc on va parler uniquement
d'après venir si vous voulez bien on m'a
souvent posé la question de savoir
pourquoi une femme je dois dire que je
me la suis pas posé à moi même c'est
venu je voulais absolument naturellement
je vois là
il n'y a pas de raison particulière
sinon un sens tout la démocratie qui
fait que pourquoi pas une femme pourquoi
pas et je suis toujours très étonnée
qu'on me pose cette question d'ailleurs
ça veut bien dire tête accrochée à ses
téléspectateurs aussi non c'était non
franchement non non non mais c'est
étonnant qu'on pose des questions ça
veut dire que c'est pas du tout entré
dans les moeurs
dans les deux cas du cas la femme
politique vous dites tout cas c'est ce
qu'on laisse imaginer séquelles que ce
soit dans morgan où les femmes de
l'ombre les hommes de l'ombre à son
propre intègre presque idéaliste c'est
ça aussi fabienne keller qui fait le
succès de de ces séries
écoutez je crois qu'ils ont touchées
simplement les français et pour moi
c'est aussi quelque chose de très beau
après essayé de l'expliquer il faut
faire attention les femmes sont diverses
a donc il faut pas attribuer des
qualités définitif mais je dois dire que
moi je m'identifie bien assez à ces deux
séries ont fait part par des bribes j'ai
passé cette prétention président de la
république alors je n'ai pas cette
prétention moi j'aime bien le terrain le
local j'aime bien ma ville mais mais
voilà dès les éléments comme ceux
relatifs à la vie très personnel qui
temps en temps télescope c'est sa vie
d'élu et ses choix d'élus c'est quelque
chose que nous vivons et voilà le voir
un film quelque part c'est quelque chose
de très fort le rôle de nathalie baye je
les écris comme sa mère je me suis dit
qu'elle était plutôt à ses novices en
matière de politique bien qu'ayant des
jeunes carrière politique mais enfin
elle a pas eu des postes fondamentaux
comme ça mais on n'a pas pensé elle au
départ pour l'élection présidentielle
mais ce sont ses qualités de huy
humaines hors appareils sur tous dans
les appareils c'est quand même quelque
chose de terrible tout à l'heure
pardonnez moi mais je vous écoute et il
confié et franchement je par exemple je
me demandais comment est ce que vous
pouviez défendre aujourd'hui une loi sur
les quatre jours et demi alors qu'en
fait tout tout les chronobiologistes
tout le monde dans l'éducation considère
que
tout le monde considère que c'est une
erreur et je me dis comment est-ce que
alors que à l'époque
à l'époque
tous enfin il y avait un consensus pour
dire qu'il fallait penser d'abord à
l'enfant et je me dis aujourd'hui on est
dans un système politique tel que on est
dans une cour de récréation c'est de 7,6
un conte de récréation êtes peut-être
d'accord là tu me parler oui devait
conserver tout ceci c'est des postures
là où on devrait effectivement je
parlais de l'enfant et de la recherche
du rythme à ce que je voulais dire c'est
que je trouve qu'il a beaucoup de
postures parfois dans le cheminement
politique et que ce que moi j'ai voulu
montrer dans les zones de l'ong c'est
justement un personnage un personnage
qui net qui était en retrait à écouter
beaucoup plus libre mais évidemment il
ya tout ce qui se passe autour et on va
loin des communicants et de tous ceux
qui gravitent autour du personnage
politique centre arrive ce sera aussi
fabienne keller avez certainement
constaté mais on peut rester très humain
mais on est quand même dans un système
qui est ce qui a ses règles et sa dureté
donc si on veut aussi pouvoir avancer il
faut le comprendre mais pas forcément
s'y plier c'est tout le défi en tout cas
de rennes des communicants à changer
complètement le paysage politique dire
que avant la guerre vous aviez des
hommes des politiques qui étaient
peut-être entouré de deux personnages
qui s'occupait de leur image mais
c'était souvent des militants politiques
s quand vous parlons je vais finir
la communication a changé a tout changé
se dire que maintenant on gouverne
beaucoup aux sondages à ce qui plaît à
ce qui plaît pas regardé par exemple la
polémique duflot valls est absolument
extraordinaire c'est à dire qu'en fait
on la juge en fonction des sondages et
non pas de la réalité ou de la
profondeur du sujet et c'est pourquoi
je suis en fait en vérité à ses
critiques à l'égard des communicants
politiques voilà de quoi peut-être faire
encore une nouvelle série présente des
eaux mais peut-être une prochaine
location
il n'est pas seulement descendante grâce
aux réseaux sociaux elle peut permettre
aussi une expression plus directe et si
elle touche elle fait alors elle fait
écho comme votre film simone estran
savais pas que communiquer autour de lui
quoi et c'était un homme de conviction
d'une heure de vol non plus d'ailleurs
seront deux exemples je vais peut-être
dire que je fais un rêve c'est d'arriver
à réconcilier un peu sur le terrain les
français la politique la fiction peut
donner à une autre image de survie
politique merci pour ce que vous fassiez
de fromage à la semaine prochaine